joining us now is chair of the sri lanka
campaign and for peace and justice
agreement shall we latter hog good to
see you on the sky news thank you very
much indeed for your time uh today i
mean these protests have been going on
for some time it just shows what
is it just a deep economic turmoil that
is gripping the country is that what's
caused all this
i think that the spark has it has been
ignited by the the economic economic
situation which has led to a
humanitarian crisis but underlying the
sentiment that the main rallying call
has been gotha go home which is about
president gautabaya rajapaksa
leaving office and
giving up power so it is really an
assertion by the sri lankan people to
take away power from those who do they
do not consider accountable who they do
not consider they do not trust anymore
and and that has been the sentiment
behind these protests
and how have the government
responded i mean we've heard today
haven't we uh prime minister wikrama
singer has agreed that he would resign
so is that going to do anything to to
dampen down these protests for instance
the main rallying call as i said before
was about gotham
who continues to demonstrate the
continuous continuation of the
rajapaksa's dynasties authoritarian rule
or rule or control over the country
since 2005. so certainly ranil
vikramasingha
giving up his seat or giving up his
position as prime minister is a symbolic
gesture but that doesn't really appease
the the majority sentiment in the
country so they really want movement
from the president action from the the
top of all this exactly they want the
president to go uh but also i don't know
if you've seen the news that um there
has been uh the the protests have now
sort of turned violent and we've seen an
attack on the prime minister's residence
it has been set on fire on fire yes
that's right and that's kind of uh a
really a step that i think all of us
watching sri lanka and concerned about
sri lanka from a distance have been
fearing all along that um any kind of
escalation any kind of violent turn of
the protests could then lead to an
authoritarian repression the military is
in standby and and we will potentially
um you know this this situation could
turn horrific
is this what we are really looking at
and can anything be done to reverse this
simply the president come out and give a
statement for instance
the president we don't know where his
where he is at the moment uh that you
know the indication that he's left the
country that his family members have
left the country it's not really clear
um you know where the president is
whether the president's sort of calling
for peace and and quiet or non-violence
will actually anger the crowds much more
who just want to see a resignation so i
think if we want to see a quelling of
the protest the first thing and the next
thing that should happen is that the
president should tender his resignation
we really are in a danger zone now is
that how you describe it with things
intensifying i think things are very
precarious in sri lanka on one hand
there's a dire humanitarian crisis we've
seen people dying uh queuing up for fuel
essential commodities surgeries have
come to a hold there has been a severe
clampdown in terms of supply of
essential goods um so there is that and
and and then and
in addition to that is the
disillusionment of the public that that
nothing is happening despite this very
horrific situation developing the
government is not responding in a manner
that they should be responding there's
no responsible
response by the government